-The Republican Party
has gone all in
on the truly pathetic claim that
Silicon Valley Bank collapsed
not because of financial
deregulation they supported,
but because the bank was woke.
In fact, they're desperately
trying to prop up
Florida governor Ron DeSantis,
the GOP's leading opponent
of so-called wokeness,
with glowing profiles
and easy interviews on Fox News.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Almost on a daily basis,
the conservative movement
finds itself
grasping for some dumb
new culture-war issue
to get audiences outraged about.
They whined about gender-neutral
Potato Head dolls,
woke LEGO sets,
and electric stoves,
and now they've moved on
to another mindless obsession --
washing machines.
-First it was your gas stoves.
Now the Biden administration
targeting your washer,
pushing new efficiency standards
as part of its global
climate agenda.
-President Biden's policies
may aim to clean the planet,
but they'll leave your clothes
dirty and smelly.
-I think we should attack them
on gas stoves.
That's the opening,
the kitchen wars.
Why are dishwashers bad?
Why are washing machines bad?
-What did I read today?
They're going after showers?
Wait, they're going after
some other goofy thing.
-Yeah, washing machines.
-Laundry. Laundry.
-Before long, you'll have to say
your preferred pronouns
to get your dishwasher to work.
-First they want my stove.
Now they want my dishwasher.
What's next? They gonna
take away my iron next?
I don't know.
-Yeah, well, look, I'm someone
who does lots of laundry.
I do laundry
for six people every week.
And so I know
a little bit about this,
and the last thing I need
is my laundry taking longer.
I'm already dealing
with a low-flow showerhead,
and my kids are coming out
with conditioner
smashed to their head
like an old "Seinfeld" episode.
And I have to tell them
to get back in and rewash.
I can't even flush my toilet one
time to get toilet paper down
because of the low-flow toilets.
-Old "Seinfeld" episode?
You think that's bad.
The other day, one of my kids
came running out of the bathroom
with his pants around his ankles
screaming, "Vandelay, Vandelay!"
Thanks to Joe Biden, he lost
his job as a latex salesman.
Also, are you listening
to yourself?
If that was the plot
of an old "Seinfeld" episode,
then it can't be a new problem.
Thanks to Joe Biden's
woke policies,
Americans are waiting for tables
at Chinese restaurants
for hours.
With that said,
I'm all for the Seinfeld'ing
of our political discourse.
I can't wait for Biden
to square off with Trump
at the presidential debates.
[ As Biden ]
Now, listen up, Donald.
I got a phone call
the other day.
And it was the jerk store.
No joke. I'm not kidding around.
And they said to me, they said,
"It's the jerk store calling.
We're running out of you."
Come on, Jack.
[ "Seinfeld" theme plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
It's so funny to think
that Biden's the Seinfeld now
when during the Obama era,
he was definitely the Kramer.
What's that? You want to know
who everyone is now?
Okay, Biden's the Seinfeld.
Kamala's the Elaine.
Bernie's the George.
And Hunter is the Kramer.
"Jerry, I can't find my laptop!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, one more tangent here.
The only reasonable complaint
about modern appliances is this.
Dishwashers are too quiet now.
It used to be you knew when
your dishwasher was running,
so you never opened it
mid-cycle,
got sprayed with hot water
while your wife yelled
from upstairs,
"Did you open
a running dishwasher again?"
forcing you to yell back,
"I didn't hear anything!"
Anyway, the GOP has
no discernible policy agenda
aside from whining
about wokeness,
a term they can't even define.
As far as I can tell,
wokeness to them just means
stuff they don't like.
In fact, rather than define
the term "wokeness" for voters,
they've already moved on
to coming up with newer
and even dumber words to
describe things they don't like.
Ron DeSantis was campaigning
in Iowa over the weekend.
He tried out this incredibly
stupid turn of phrase.
-Because woke ideology has
infected so many institutions,
if you really want to protect
the freedom of your folks,
you got to be willing
to defend them against the left
imposing their pathologies
on your people
in any of these institutions.
So we've got to fight
if we see it in medicine
or the universities
or the corporations.
You can't just say, "Let it go,"
because then
we're gonna be living
under an oppressive
"woke-ocracy."
-Ooh.
Well, that just rolls right off
the tongue -- woke-ocracy.
Pretty sure saying that
gives you strep throat.
The only -- only way
this makes sense
is if it's a ploy by DeSantis
to come up with a new word
that's such a mouthful,
Donald Trump can't pronounce it
and then melts down in a debate.
[ As Trump ] You know, Ron,
he likes to talk about
the woke-a-croky.
I mean the waka-crazy.
I mean the waka-coca-racy-shock.
Look, folks,
we're living in Wakanda.
We have to admit it.
We're living in Wakanda,
and if we're not careful,
it's gonna be Wakanda forever.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] DeSantis's
obsession with battling wokeness
has made him a subject
of fawning profiles
and softball interviews
on Fox News.
On Monday, he did an interview
with Fox host Brian Kilmeade
where they had a catch
at a baseball field.
-We're on a baseball field.
You've had a busy day.
But you wanted
to come to this field
because it means so much to you,
obviously.
Even though I'm a soccer player,
do you have time for a catch?
-Let's do it. I'll do it.
Yeah, alright.
-If not this time
to run for president,
would you think at some time
it's safe to say
that that would be
one of your goals?
-I would only --
I would only do stuff
if I thought
there was a rationale for me
to accomplish things
on behalf of the people.
So it's all substance-driven
about whether I could serve
or not serve
in a variety of capacities.
-Oh, someone get a radar gun
on those guys.
Somehow during the course
of that interview,
three runners scored.
This interview's the worst thing
to happen on a baseball field
since Randy Johnson
exploded that bird.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
If it had been DeSantis throwing
instead of Randy,
that bird would have been fine.
Light bruising at best.
And look, I know that clip
is kind of a bummer.
So if it helps,
that bird would have died
of old age by now anyway.
[ Laughter ]
I said if it helped.
But, yes, it's great to see Opie
and Sheriff Taylor over here
enjoying the old
American tradition
that fathers and sons
have engaged in for decades --
putting on your suits
and lapel mics
for a game of catch
in front of a camera crew.
Also, of course, Fox picked
their saddest button-eyed bozo,
Brian Kilmeade, to have a catch
with a politician.
Kilmeade's probably
been dreaming about this.
I would have loved
to have seen the pre-interview.
"Alright, we're just gonna
toss the ball back and forth.
I'll ask you about wokeness.
And one more thing.
Is it okay if I call you Dad?"
[ Laughter ]
But that's how desperate
the leaders of the conservative
movement are to embrace DeSantis
and his crusade
against so-called wokeness.
They are a thoroughly
unserious political movement.
So whining about wokeness
is their answer for everything.
For example, after the collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank
last week,
Republicans didn't blame
financial deregulation
or the recklessness
of venture-capitalist tech bros.
They blamed wokeness.
Senator Roger Marshall
called SVB
"a woke California bank."
Donald Trump Jr. tweeted...
And Senator Josh Hawley
tweeted...
Yeah, man, I'm tired of all
these radical leftist banks
taking my money,
spending it on woke products
like credit default swaps
and mortgage-backed securities.
The other day -- true story --
I asked to meet
with my banker at Chase,
and when I walked in, who was
sitting across the desk from me?
None other than
the new green M&M.
And she told me the bank
invested all my money
in a mutual fund that consists
of critical race theory
and electric stoves.
And then I knew my money
was really in trouble
when I saw her get up
to grab a pen
and she wasn't wearing
high heels anymore.
She was wearing...flats.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Evil screaming ]
-[ Echoing ] Woke-ocracy.
[ Laughter ]
-This has to be one of
the silliest talking points
I've ever heard in my life.
The word "woke bank"
would honestly be so funny
if they weren't
so deadly serious about it.
If a bank can be woke,
then that means
literally anything can be woke.
And GOP senators
weren't the only ones
pushing this pathetic narrative
that wokeness
is somehow responsible
for a bank run caused entirely
by deregulation
and reckless
venture-capitalist tech bros.
There was also Fox News,
which went so far as to blame
the Obama administration
for the collapse of SVB.
-Remember that after 2008,
the Obama administration,
Eric Holder, swooped in
and imposed DEI --
diversity, equity,
and inclusion -- standards
on the entire financial sector.
And that's one of the main
reasons our big banks
are now increasingly incompetent
and also one of the reasons
Americans are so divided
by race.
Ideologues used
the 2008 bank bailout
to kill American meritocracy.
-That's right,
they killed meritocracy
so they could replace it
with woke-acaca-roka-cracy.
[ Laughter ]
First of all,
the 2008 bailout was Bush.
Second, do you know
how much harder
Obama could have been
on the banks?
He could have nationalized them
or restored
the Glass-Steagall division
between commercial
and investment banking.
But he didn't. You think
he secretly made them woke
and that's why
they're collapsing now.
[ As Obama ] Alright,
Goldman Sachs, listen up.
You can have a bailout
and keep all the money.
But in return, I'm gonna
make washing machines suck.
And you're not going to
try to stop me.
[ Normal voice ] Now,
as we explained on Monday,
the SVB collapse
was actually the fault
of panicky tech VCs who rushed
to pull all their money out
and a bipartisan push
to repeal financial rules
for mid-sized banks back in 2018
that was signed into law
by President Trump.
In fact, you know who also voted
to repeal those
Dodd-Frank reforms
when he was a little-known
congressman from Florida?
None other than
Ron "The Heater" DeSantis.
That's right,
DeSantis voted with Trump
to gut Wall Street
regulations in 2018.
So it shouldn't be
surprising at all
that DeSantis is now
going on Fox News
blaming the collapse on,
you guessed it,
diversity, equity,
and inclusion.
-I mean, this bank, they're so
concerned with DEI and politics
and all kinds of stuff.
I think that really diverted
from them focusing
on their core mission.
-In fact, this bank was so woke,
the CEO went on TV
the other day,
and he had shampoo
all over his head.
I mean, honestly, is anyone
buying this [bleep]
What's next?
Oh, my God.
Are they going to start
closing banks
for woke new holidays
like Festivus?
Again, I didn't bring it up.
As we noted on Monday,
it wasn't just Republicans
who supported
the push to deregulate.
Many centrist Democrats
voted to repeal
the Dodd-Frank rules, too.
Even Barney Frank, whose name
was on the original bill,
ended up sitting on the board
of Signature Bank,
which also collapsed,
and supported the push
to ease some of the financial
regulations he passed.
Do you know how crazy that is?
That's like if your name
was Mike Whirlpool
and you wanted to abolish...
-Washing machines.
-The few progressives
who loudly opposed the changes
included senators Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren.
In fact, today,
Warren went on TV
to talk about the 2018 law
repealing the requirements
for mid-sized banks
to conduct stress tests,
basically tests to make sure
that banks have enough liquidity
or cash
to weather a storm
like this one.
And when the anchor
suggested that banks
were doing stress tests
on their own
and didn't need government
regulators to oversee the tests,
Warren laughed.
-We've had a number
of those CEOs
on the shows in the last few
days -- Fifth Third, Schwab.
They do their own
stress testing.
Not everyone was behaving
in a risk profile
and a risk manner that
Silicon Valley Bank was.
-[ Laughs ] I'm sorry.
I taught school
for many, many years,
and I did not let my students
do their own testing.
-Of course not.
You can't even let students
bring their tests home,
or they'll turn an "F"
into an "A"
before they show their parents.
I'm willing to bet Warren
was one of those cool teachers
who would grill her students
but then give them
invaluable life guidance
while sitting backwards
on a chair.
"You got talent, Brad,
but you got to use it.
Now, what do you say
we go out back
and take a hit off this joint?
I know a good spot
by the baseball field.
Only losers hang out there."
The Republican Party
has once again revealed itself
as a thoroughly
unserious political movement
by blaming a banking crisis
they caused on wokeness,
a term they can't even define.
To put it politely,
Republicans are full
of a certain substance
you might find sitting in...
-Low-flow toilets.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]